ALLIES, DANA.
>> PHIL, THANK YOU FOR THAT
REPORTING.
>>> AHEAD OF THAT DISCUSSION
THAT PHIL WAS JUST TALKING
ABOUT, UKRAINE'S DEFENSE
MINISTER SAT DOWN FOR AN
EXCLUSIVE INTERVIEW WITH CNN
SAYING HE WANTS PRESIDENT BIDEN
TO TAKE AN EVEN FIRMER STANCE
WITH VLADIMIR PUTIN.
MAKE IT CLEAR THAT THE U.S. WILL
NOT HESITATE TO ACT IF RUSSIA
MOVES TO INVADE UKRAINE.
HE TELLS MATTHEW CHANCE THE
SUPPORT THEY WANT DOES NOT
INCLUDE SENDING AMERICAN
SOLDIERS TO FIGHT ON THEIR FRONT
LINES.
>> I HOPE THAT THEY WILL EMPTY
FOREVER.
>> THESE ARE THE GUYS THAT HAVE
ALREADY LOST THEIR LIVES.
THESE COULD SOON BE FILLED.
>> Reporter: THIS IS THE REAL
THREAT.
UKRAINE NOW FACES.
MORE SOLDIERS DIEING IN BATTLES
WITH RUSSIA, SOMETHING THE
COUNTRY'S NEW DEFENSE MINISTER
APPOINTED JUST A MONTH AGO TELLS
ME HE IS STRUGGLING WITH.
>> IN RUSSIA, THEY WILL HAVE
ALSO THE SAME FACES.
RUSSIANS WILL DIE.
FOR WHAT?
>> Reporter: ACROSS THE BORDER,
THE KREMLIN CALLS THESE ITS
REGULAR WINTER DRILLS.
UKRAINE SAYS THERE ARE NOW ABOUT
95,000 RUSSIAN TROOPS WITHIN
STRIKING DISTANCE.
U.S. INTEL INDICATES THAT WILL
RISE TO 175,000.
BUT EVEN THAT, THE DEFENSE
MINISTER TELLS ME, IS AN
UNDERESTIMATE.
>> 175, IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO GO TO
UKRAINE.
>> YOU THINK RUSSIA WILL NEED
MORE THAN 175,000?
>> YES.
>> HOW MUCH MORE IS UNCLEAR.
BUT THESE LATEST SATELLITE
IMAGES FROM RUSSIA SUGGESTS
MOSCOW IS NOW ENGAGED IN AN
UNPRECEDENTED BUILD UP NEAR THE
UKRAINIAN FRONTIER.
ENOUGH TO MOUNT AN OVERWHELMING
INVASION.
ALARMING THE U.S. AND NATO.
ALTHOUGH UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS
SEEM CALM AT WHAT LOOKS LIKE AN
IMMINENT THREAT.
>> I WOULD SAY THAT THE
DIFFERENT MEANS THAT WE'RE NOT
IN FEAR MOOD.
SO WE HAVE NO CHANCE TO BE ON
THIS -- PUSHING OF THIS.
>> YOU'RE NOT FEARFUL OF A
RUSSIAN INVASION?
IS THAT BECAUSE YOU DON'T
BELIEVE THE INTELLIGENCE?
>> NO, NO, NO.
WE BELIEVE THROUGH OUR INTEL.
WE BELIEVE TO ALL FACTS THAT WAS
FIXED BY THE UNITED STATES INTEL
AND ET CETERA.
>> BUT DO YOU BELIEVE RUSSIA
WILL INVADE?
DO YOU BELIEVE RUSSIA WILL
INVADE?
>> I AM NOT BELIEVE THAT -- I
WILL NOT BELIEVE THAT RUSSIA
WILL HAVE A VICTORY IN UKRAINE.
IT'S A DIFFERENT.
BECAUSE IT WILL BE A REALLY
BLOODY MASSACRE AND RUSSIAN GUYS
ALSO WILL COME BACK IN THE
COFFINS.
>> Reporter: THERE'S ALSO A
BELIEF IN UKRAINE THAT RUSSIA,
WHICH DENIES PLANS TO INVADE,
CAN, WITH THE HELP OF THE UNITED
STATES AND ITS ALLIES, STILL BE
DETERRED.
THIS IS THE DEFENSE MINISTER
INDUCTING TWO NEW COASTAL PATROL
BOATS FROM THE U.S. INTO THE
UKRAINIAN NAVY.
PART OF A MUCH BROADER MILITARY
MODERNIZATION PROGRAM UKRAINE IS
TRYING TO CARRY OUT WITH SUPPORT
FROM THE WEST.
ANGERING MOSCOW.
UKRAINIAN'S GROWING TIES WITH
NATO AND KREMLIN DEMANDS FOR
NATO EXPANSION TO BE CURBED IS
SET TO DOMINATE PRESIDENT
BIDEN'S VIRTUAL SUMMIT WITH
VLADIMIR PUTIN OF RUSSIA ON
TUESDAY.
A CRUCIAL ONLINE MEETING THAT
COULD DETERMINE UKRAINE'S FATE.
THE U.S. PRESIDENT, THE DEFENSE
MINISTER TELLS ME, SHOULD DOUBLE
DOWN ON SUPPORT FOR UKRAINE.
>> IF I CAN ADVISE PRESIDENT
BIDEN, I WOULD LIKE TO ASK HIM
TO VERY UNDERSTANDABLE
ARTICULATE TO MR. PUTIN THAT NO
RED LINES FROM KREMLIN SIDE
COULD BE HERE.
RED LINE IS HERE IN UKRAINE.
AND CIVILIZED WORLD WILL REACT
WITHOUT ANY HESITATION.
WE DON'T NEED THE AMERICAN OR
CANADIAN SOLDIERS HERE TO FIGHT
FOR UKRAINE.
WE WILL FIGHT BY OURSELVES.
BUT WE NEED ORGANIZATIONAL
WEAPONRY, WE NEED ELECTRONIC
WARFARE AND ET CETERA.
>> Reporter: THE PROBLEM WITH
AMERICA AND NATO AND OTHERS
STEPPING UP THEIR HELP, THEIR
ASSISTANCE FOR UKRAINE IS THAT
IT COULD POTENTIALLY PROVOKE THE
KREMLIN EVEN FURTHER.
COULD BE POKING THE BEAR AND
FORCE THEM TO INVADE.
IS THAT A CONCERN FOR YOU?
DO YOU THINK THAT'S REALISTIC?
>> THE IDEA DON'T PROVOKE RUSSIA
WILL NOT WORK.
I'M SURE.
>> WHY?
>> BECAUSE GEORGIA, SALISBURY,
CRIMEA.
>> YOU THINK CONFRONTATION WITH
RUSSIA IS THE ONLY WAY TO STOP
RUSSIA'S MALIGN ACTIVITY AROUND
THE WORLD?
>> NOT ONLY CONFRONTATION.
IT COULD BE VERY -- IT SHOULD BE
STRONG POSITION.
WE ARE PARTNERS OF UKRAINE.
WE WILL HELP THEM IN ALL KIND OF
WAYS TO DO IT.
>> AND THE KREMLIN WILL HEAR
THAT AND IT WILL UNDERSTAND THAT
AND IT WILL STOP?
>> I AM SURE.
>> Reporter: IT IS A HIGH-STAKES
GAMBLE WITH NO GUARANTEE SUCH A
HARD LINE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
TO THE KREMLIN WILL DO ANYTHING
TO FORCE RUSSIA BACK.
DANA, UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS ARE
EXPRESSING GRATITUDE FOR THE
CONTINUED STRATEGIC SUPPORT OF
THE UNITED STATES.
PRESIDENT ZELENSKY OF UKRAINIAN
TWEETED HE HAD DISCUSSIONS WITH
ANTONY BLINKEN ABOUT AGREED
POSITIONS BEFORE THE MEETING
BETWEEN PRESIDENT BIDEN AND
PRESIDENT PUTIN AS IT GOES AHEAD
TOMORROW.
NOTHING ABOUT UKRAINE WITHOUT
UKRAINE.
THAT'S WHAT HE TWEETED AMID
THESE ASSURANCES THAT HE WILL BE
CONSULTED ALL ALONG THE WAY IN
THESE DISCUSSIONS BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND THE RUSSIANS.
>> WHAT A FASCINATING AND
INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT INTERVIEW
THAT YOU DID THERE.
LET ME ALSO ASK YOU ABOUT
SOURCES TELLING CNN THAT
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS CONSIDERING
SANCTIONS AGAINST PUTIN'S INNER
CIRCLE.
HOW ARE KREMLIN SOURCES TELLING
YOU THAT THEY PLAN TO RESPOND?
>> WELL, THEY'RE NOT PREPARED TO
ANSWER THAT HEAD ON.
THEY'VE CALLED IT -- THE KREMLIN
SPOKESMAN TODAY CALLED IT
INFORMATION HYSTERIA.
THAT THERE WOULD BE ANY KIND OF
SANCTIONS IMPOSED ON RUSSIA
BECAUSE OF THIS.
RUSSIA DENIES ANY PLANS FOR
HAVING AN INVASION OF UKRAINE
BUT THEY MUST BE MINDFUL OF THE
FACT THAT THE UNITED STATES AND
OTHERS IN THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY HAVE SANCTIONED RUSSIA
REPEATEDLY FOR ITS ACTIVITIES
AROUND THE WORLD AND PERHAPS THE
THREAT OF THE KIND OF SEVERE
SANCTIONS THAT THE UNITED STATES
AND ITS ALLIES ARE NOW SORT OF